yeah long start to the game for those guys and
ottawa's had two lines hit the ice so far playing
with some Pace you got to be careful the centers
had a lot of talented players out here that shot
by Kevin Hayes fought off by Corp pasalo Hayes
had two goals in a span of 31 seconds the other
night in that 64 loss to Detroit here's Ridley
Greg number 71 lost it Neighbors in with tchenko
Jake neighbors dips the shoulder to the net and
he can't get it on goal defended by Hamond now a
shot by ful got through and a save here is tchenko
backhander on goal saved by cor pasalo and then
kept the line by fol corenko neighbors and Haze
the forward group for the blues and corenko now
to Hay right in front rebound attempt and a save
by Corpus Salo as they Jam away and it's kept
out of there by the finished goendale a round for
McKenzie McAn recalled yesterday from Springfield
MC gang leaves it sunquist shoots it on goal and a
save by corpo good chance there for Oscar sunquist
he comes in great pass cre to bage right in front
tipped on goal and trickler goes in on Corpus Salo
and he covers up and then KR digs it off the wall
that would hide now for davit lets it fly right
on goal and a save Again by Corpus Salo kept in by
pero the round back now for S he scored the first
goal the other night against Detroit now back for
pero wi fires right on goal and a save by Corpus
Salo in his 38th NHL game of course played a lot
in Springfield for Drew banister one of 11 blues
that have played for banister at some point now
faul wide open shoots it right on goal and a save
Again by corpa Salo and can chuck to the corner
for jaru slowed down by Faulk and then Tory crew
gets it back for St Louis and now Fulk ahead
Thomas Breakaway in the clear he scores Robert
Thomas a breakaway goal and the blues lead one-
nothing as he hustles through the middle of the
ice Justin ful sends it little deflection there
and then Robert Thomas does a little shake and
bake and finds the five hole on this one under
pressure just great body control here and then
pulls it around the stick there if we look at it
from the plazatire goalie Camp Corella recovered
by Shen around to Thomas again shot rebound
B davage hit the goal post and in the slot
the blues can't get to it and they dump it in Tory
Krug back to get it on with Shen Thomas navage and
sunst pass ahead kro got a breakway in the CLA and
a save by Corpus Salo if you watch your toy crew
drops it then continues to that open Ice gets all
the way in here and then Coro makes the safe for
the sunu big save but this is another break great
Tor Krug has had here had a couple in the last few
games as M try to tip it in Thomas on his knees
good play back and now on to crew back to fall
shoots it say rebound they score Robert Thomas
again and the blues have taken it two nothing
lead Blues Robert Thomas getting his second goal
of the Night by The Blues we get a look here as
they zip the puck around here good Puck retrieval
in the corner nice play to the point here and then
Robert Thomas goes right to the front of the net
after making that great play and gets a backhand
on it there stays with the puck and puts home the
rebound as we see here right here knocks it down
out of the air and then finishes it right there
on the back and that's his second two-goal game
in the last four seven three multi-goal game
has never had a hatrick maybe tonight is the
night for Robert Thomas goes off the face
off cber C into Ley right in pass across
face score Brandon s what a pass and what a goal
and the blowers have taken a three nothing lead
this play starts right up high here look at Colt
Paro under pressure by Brady kchu takes the hit
moves it down low then a lot of patience by Jordan
kyou and then look at Nick lety on this play Waits
out waights it out just a beautiful job by Nick
lety by keeping his feet going just enough to
get around the full body slide now the puck to
Center Ice gos up three nothing 945 left in the
second sunquist Hit It Center and Ottawa gets it
and a backhander and they score as kubal gets it
through the legs at Bennington and sunquist was
in some difficulty after that hit yeah a bit of
a weird sequence on this entire goal right here
a little bit of a Blindside there by the Senators
forward Sunny feeling it right there and then
there was another hit that happened after and
then out of nowhere Greg ends up all by himself
here with the puck or rather kubal sorry ends up
by himself that is steered in by Ridley gray
played by benon what a pass it had to Thomas
and just like that a three on two that buich
to Kyu in on goal and a save by coras Salo on
Kyu nice pass up on the wing for Brandon saw
onto the side of shen he comes in Shen shoots
it off the crossbar oh Shen off the crossbar and
no cing gets it windes and fires broke his stick
and a pat save by corao then neighbers across the
Tucker and look out lost it and Joseph raises in
with a break and a great save by Bennington
on Joseph who raced in on right wing Jordan
Bennington here facing Joseph big BL loer save
right there to crew and to head to Thomas he's got
two tonight Thomas waiting great pass to B dich
gets it back he scores B dich 4-1 Blues what a
play Blues make it 4-1 here on Pavo bnic is great
one time goal as we move ahead a little give and
go and give and go and pav bich rips it there
pointing at Jordan cyou they just moved this
Puck around here the poor Ottawa net mind here
Corpus Salo is almost in the corner now covered
by giru with 615 left Senators dump it in here's
F OHA pass up the middle picked off jeru shoots
it off the goal post after a giveaway you don't
see Faulk do that very often and used his skating
ability well kept in terceo for stla shoots it and
a save by benington and he got the rebound as well
on STL talked about the crease coverage last break
but look at this one save sticks with it here pad
out again two on the a at 6:30 on Valley Sports
now Joseph back to the line to this side for
CH R shot they score might have been tipped in
front and it's now now 42 now Jordan Bennington
immediately motioning that it was a high stick
complaining so we'll have to get a good look at
it I I felt like I heard a tip in front of the net
from down here seems like a harmless play Here by
Jacob Chan as he wrists it on net or rather Greg
risks it on [Music] net we follow that puck it is
high right there and then o boy Jordan Bennington
may have a case here you look at the Plaza Tire
goalie cam is jph in front reaches up that's above
the crossbar in my opinion and he thought for a
second for empty net goal there he did he thought
and a shot wide that's going to do it and the
blues are going to snap a losing streak and Drew
Brest bisher rather his first win as an NHL coach